matthieu delormeau on va voir ce que tu
as fait cette saison
toi tu es fier de toi on est ce que d
autres sont fiers de toi tu penses que
tu vas voir combien sur twitter la
langue n'était semaine dernière les fans
vraie voix des téléspectateurs
ouais 8,8 d'accord on verra dresse un
raisonnable on verra nos instants moi je
pense que tu as plus de chances d'avoir
0,8 que la nature de leurs bons matthieu
delormeau c'est avant tout un animateur
à succès il ya quatre ans donc je me
fais remercier d'nrj12 jo ça j'en ai
fait les frais à qui on doit des
émissions de qualité à dieu vous avez
fait ça on peut pas vous l'enlever vous
avez fait ouf mais plus qu'un animateur
mathieu est un artiste aux multiples
talents auxquels chéri il croit beaucoup
ou assez bien me diriger la vers le
théâtre très prochainement c'est la
première c'est un one man est ce que
vous produire y est allé jeu
en attendant son one man show mathieu et
chroniqueur dans tpm paix est là encore
il est parfait modestes ou presque parce
que vous trouvez vous je profite de
cette peine une seconde comme donné pour
remercier les fans notamment de
l'étranger d'autres continents qui vont
souhaiter bon anniversaire
pas même au canada où quand je me
connais je sais avec des avis tranchés
oui si noble âge est sérieux c'est 8 ça
va être la chaîne premium est en réalité
c'est que des reprises
moi je suis très ami avec claire chazal
c'est une femme qu'un certain âge et
qu'il ne méritait pas ça des bêtises et
toujours bien informé
la peine parce que tu es un jingle ans
parce que j'ai un scoop tu verras ça
arriverait un jour mon bref excellent
bilan pour l'élève mathieu mais
attention à ne pas trop faire le rebelle
avec le prof
oui petite anecdote qui avoue faire
baisser un peu d'un ton mot grands pools
grandes gueules l'a20
[Applaudissements]
matthieu delormeau
c'est son conseil de classe on va
démarrer
on va démarrer par géraldine maillet
gens de savoir ce qu'elle pense de
matthieu delormeau et condamnés alors
cher mathieu cher de leur malheur on
commence comme quand elle écrit une
lettre un cher mathieu cher ici dans le
pas-de-calais
nancy 108 9 et bébé bazinet du château
henri mathieu toi et ton avril
vous n'avez que des qualités tu es drôle
tu le sais tu es intelligent tu le sais
tu es beau tu le sais pas et musclé tu
le sais et qu'ont-ils le soutenir a dit
non à la fermeture des lits jerry paix
gerry la nuit tu fermes ta gueule on
passera la journée demain en somme on se
rapporte aux patrons et à est connu on
sera en ami on va s'appliquer tout les
12 g ripper droite au classement je suis
et délicieusement faux culs des tul
c'est fou comment je vais d eric venner
tu le sais est derrière toutes ces
certitudes
ce qui me plaît c'est que tu es un homme
qui est pétri de doutes et c'est ça qui
me paraît le plus touchant un choix des
fonds c'est donc j'ai failli connaître
une très très très bon petit coin et
puis tout à coup j'ai pensé à tes
défauts et y en a un pour moi qui est
rédhibitoire
tu pue du cul
[Rires]
mais
[Applaudissements]
surtout pour moi c'est tout pour moi
perso
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les airs en barre est à nous et ouais
alors là jamie était moi vous préférez
au défi d'être on peut tomber sur
quelqu'un qui est plus si j'ai cette
impression
ah bah oui mais pression aussi bien sur
ce côté là tu as montré très bon essor
de boys band à toi tout seul je déteste
la manière de dire tout le temps many
many as is a rien que pour ça moi je
trouve que c'est insupportable c'est
violent je trouve que c'est dégueulasse
donc tu avais linaf et du coup jeté ni 3
[Applaudissements]
tu vois tu es toi que tu ne te calmer tu
vas me suis calmé jean michel mr ton
meilleur ami est ce que les 2 c les deux
sont comme ça mathieu je reste non je
vais vous surprendre je vais rester soft
pour pas le gêner c'est vrai qu'il est
assez pudique mais pour moi c'est vrai
que tu es le cerveau taking tu es le
boss et le singe voilà si on réunit
toutes les qualités qu'on cherchait un
homme thomas einstein dans le corps de
brad pitt et sa maman d'ici là c'est du
sérieux les jaloux or il est très
pertinent je trouve des tours à contre
courant des fidèles a décidé que je
n'avais jamais oui mais je le pense
vraiment voilà je suis déjà mais langue
de bois il n'hésite pas se fâcher que
tout le monde même avec vous quand voilà
quand il n'a pas là mais ils pensent pas
comme vous bon rien que pour ça je peux
dire je suis très fier d'être ton ami et
je t'aime je te mets disent oh la la
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr pourquoi t'es pas gai et les
relie koshita kelly on est d'accord à
steinbach hashtag c'est bon on s'est
compris c'était très beau c'est ça ma
touche hashtag je me laisse daniel
halévy à vous à moi à toi oui alors
mathieu
j'aime beaucoup ta franchise ta frange
au oui c'est un titi petit j'aime
beaucoup ta franchise ça t'arrive
souvent d'être marrant je lave ou en
revanche oui en revanche je trouve très
méchant avec tes camarades vraiment
sache pas juste un vieux pour ça tu est
très méchant avec tes camarades et tu
n'es pas le nombril de l'émission bah
ouais moi tu es vraiment pas le nombril
de limoges où tu le saches aussi ça
regarde pas souvent les courbes
d'audience mais 1,5 parce que je suis
très gentil bon c'est pas mal elle est
sévère celle ci un vrai sévère oui mais
elle bonne note
ouais tout ça partait bien belles
tomates sa gueule ouais mais ça qu'on
l'a pas gâté
j'enchaîne crédit agathe les deux des
deux est mieux quand deux amis sont à
côté j'ai envie de l'aider à l'aller il
est bien sûr là mathieu comptes m
on compte des tests il faut trop
connaître un véritable sens de la
répartie dussault bas alors même si tu
préfère me raconter tes plans cul plutôt
que de donner des infos médias tués pour
moi le meilleur chroniqueur de
l'émission c'est sûr qu'il a plus de
points que d'infos médias
c'est sûr ça c'est sûr que s'il avoue
autour d'un forum il ya que deux plans
cul pourrait faire un dictionnaire
[Applaudissements]
c'était une belle année mais l'année
bravo pour ça aussi
merci tu viens surtout proclamé artistes
ouais et moi je pense véritablement que
tu en es un tué un amuseur un clown
saltimbanque donc temps placé dans un
cirque non tu as ce sens inné du
divertissement qui fait que quand tu
n'es pas dans l'émission ça se ressente
lui apporte énormément d'humeur et de
force au programme
pour moi tu mérites 1,9 j'ai toujours
préféré qu'il y a en tout cas je sais
pas ce qui se passe mais elle a changé
d'avis sur où j'ai l'impression que les
mouches ont changé d'âne est s'est
toujours dit que maintenant c'était un
connard mais que le chroniqueur c'était
le meilleur en tout cas oui bernard
montiel
alors moi c'est très curieux cher
mathieu parce que évidemment on te voit
comme ça c'était sympathique c'est le
bon ben t'as l'air du bon mais qu'en
fait tu balances tout je voudrais quand
même dire que tu critiques tout le monde
c'est curieux et je me demande si à
chaque fois je le fais exprès ou si
c'est un personnage que tu t'es créé a
effectivement tué très drôle parfois
tual la répartie parfois donc avec toi
je ne sais pas comment il faut aborder
ou ne pas aborder du tout d'ailleurs
faux nom
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout
ce cas c'est un ses cris
à l'autre qui passe derrière
castany quand il m'accuse pas toujours
la pression qui vient de perdre ça
m'agace hal gill à ma pagaie
il a toujours la démarche du gag qui va
me faire de l'oseille à une carte jean
maintenant c'est vrai bah alors je
t'adore
j'en peux plus alors on s'attendait
certes pas ou feint jésus et commence à
aborder
j'ai changé le vert d'aborder je dis
simplement avec toi on ne sait pas
justement où est la réalité d'un
personnage sympathique encore
effectivement tu balances sur les
camarades je me demande si c'est vrai
s'il ya du fond a hérité ou pas et ça ça
me gêne vous voulez que j'abrège non 5
pourquoi c'est intéressant parce que
papa ski sais pas si je suis un vrai
connard ou info connard ça c'est un truc
que tu vas mourir au calme ouais c'est
vrai la raison c'est en fait la moitié
merci au staff je peux vous répondre aux
épaules gaz où il est installé
oui allez vous avez habité pendant de
nombreuses années un poteau lui
mais il va voir à quel point je l'aimais
la preuve c'est que mathieu si tu
réponds tu confonds tu confonds tête et
pmp avec un incident de rencontre où un
salon coiffure sacs à ordures de parler
des couleurs de cheveux des invités ou
deux des nombreuses conquêtes un niveau
médias un fossé s'est quasiment nul
pire que ça et ça je ne comprends même
pas ils le supportent
tu n'arrêtes pas d'insinuer que le
patron bachand et de fanfares mon petit
gars t'es pas prêt de se faire trop
bonne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on attendra qu'elle a dit son trombone
et non pas sa trompette
oui c'est vrai en revanche pointé coup
de cymbale j'espère possibilités tu va
pas tarder à me faire chier et néanmoins
comme dirait isabelle tu extrêmement
drôle et sincèrement tu es l'un des
piliers de l'émission à ça quand tu n'es
pas là tu manques
ouais ça qui me manque à moi et encore
plus ce nom at on pu rester un jour il
m'a dit je suis je veux que tu viens de
nos émissions non pas parce que
l'émission est meilleur quand tu la mets
parce que je suis moins bon quand on
voit là c'était cette pratique mais
alors c'est quelqu'un qui s'est fait
passer pour alors pas moi je te lis et
quelqu'un m'a dit cinq ans
oh my way qui ont été dites pour toutes
ces raisons et parce que tu es tu es mon
pote et que et que je t'aime
magnifique 2
[Applaudissements]
béthune à la christine kelly alors tim
kelly la note de deux lambeaux et
l'appréciation alors moi je suis tombée
amoureuse de matthieu delormeau nord
demain vraiment m et toi tu es un non
mais c'est vrai je lui ai dit d'ailleurs
alors je voulais dit il à 1,5 dollar
ordinaire un sens de la répartie
extraordinaire que j'ai rarement vu
voilà il a beaucoup d'humour moi je m'en
fous que tu emmènes des infos média ou
pas ma seule chose et je te le dis c'est
que tu connais mon camp m'a tuer là
vraiment c'est toute une ambiance qu'on
serait une juste avant de vision quand
t'es pas là ça n'a rien à voir quand et
là tout de suite c'est de la vie bien
mais en plus on n'est pas à l'antenne
onze chiens tôt mais voilà tu es
lumineux franchement mâché violent fait
endurer car on a eu les nerfs parce que
juste on a peur qui se passe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là c'est à chaque match et là faut faire
pour mettre une interdiction aux moins
de 10 ans parce que tu parles que des
blagues en dessous de la ceinture
je voulais te le dire mais c'est tout en
purgeant tant qu'il est là l'émission
bascule
c'est vrai c'est le centre garde je te
mets 7
merci tout va mal
isabelle à mathieu vos petits déjeuners
avec cyril moi pas premier motif
d'agacement vous allez à roland garros
avec lui moi pas deuxième motif
d'agacement
il est derrière vous vous adorez sa
troisième motif d'agacement
oh oui à part ça côtoyé mathieu c'est
exactement aimé lancement vous était
sont tous ceux qui essaient dégrippant
akono mars a côtoyé mathieu c'est comme
au sommet du mont blanc c'est à dire que
l'air se raréfie pour toutes les
personnes sont autour de toi parce que
tu bouffes tout l'oxygène
tu fais ton émission dans le loufoque
look si j'ai donc ça et puis sa série
incroyable c'est un peu tous pour toi et
pas pour personne ou pas ou pas grand
monde et puis tu es assez négligent vers
les gens pour bien me dire non pas dire
très indifférent et très méchant coup et
ma part ça tu me fais rire vous verrez
honte et je suis ton meilleur
souffre-douleur je lis parce qu'elle est
mignonne commune d'abobo du besoin de
quoi tu es mention avec elle promet
jamais tu est incontournable même si je
le regrette et tu m'énerves mais je
t'aime beaucoup voient la télé comme un
gentil à berlin ban avec endemol
regardez je m'y arrête a vu là bas deux
points forts c'est l'invention
vous êtes un conteur extraordinaire vous
jugez les émissions sans les voir comme
vous faites vos documentaires sans les
travailler
[Applaudissements]
non mais t'as bien cerner alors vos
points faibles forme un fil ininterrompu
qui fait 5 fois le tour de la terre j'en
ai choisi juste 2 la mythomanie et
serait pas possible vous vivez dans un
monde imaginaire vous vous rêvez le
meilleur mais ça va prendre
l'égocentrisme
ouais y en a que pour vous c'est dingue
est ce que je ne supporte pas et ça je
vous le dis vraiment sincèrement les
yeux dans les yeux c'est que vous vous
en preniez à isabelle s en prendre à
isabelle c'est ce regard des mois mais
sans plus c'est s'en prendre à moi et
vous me trouverez sur votre chemin
alors apparemment je me suis renseigné
ya patenaude négative ici c'est pour ça
que j'ai été obligé de vous mettre un
trop flatteur 0 à bolton pas alors vous
aviez prévu
j'avais prévu pour la note des tweetos
on va voir tout de suite combien les
plus tôt douze ont mis alors cette
survie des rubis des chroniqueurs 5,9 et
trois de leurs baux moi je ne mets plus
de notes merci je ne veux plus de
problèmes numérique le coeur avec le
coeur ce sera à moins 2
merci